we search the country to find the most
talented young chefs from all over
america i want to open a restaurant
before i'm 18. culinary prodigies on the
road to stardom i posted this beef
wellington i made
two and a half million views but
they won't take this journey alone
competing on top chef with somebody you
love it's just a beautiful thing this is
how we grow
they can bring a grandma a mom a dad an
auntie an uncle it's like a science
experiment
they're gonna be up against the best
kids in the country i may be the
youngest one here but that doesn't mean
i can't cook i can feel how nervous you
are because your hands are sweating
this guy is looking at me i don't know
anything about cooking what are you all
about is that big i don't know who in
the room was like you know who should
host this cooking show is meghan trainor
but i love them for it was it you it's
me whoa i didn't even know things could
taste like this i love truffle well you
are very high-end i'm so excited very
jessie spano of you my mouth is watering
[Applause]
we'll have this in our memories for a
lifetime i mean they blew my mind
it's so good i didn't expect that we
killed that i'm gonna hire all of you
what's the hourly day
at stake 50 000 to bring the winning
families culinary dreams to life and the
chance to be crowned the champions of
top shot family style
[Music]
you